real talk is helping kids and our
community
and findlay automotive is a big part of
that joining us to talk
more about that is findlay automotive
cfo
tyler corder how you doing tyler i'm
doing great kendall how are you
great let's talk about real talk how is
this impacting young people
so this is one of my favorite local
charities a lady named sheree cornell
founded it here she's the next probation
officer and what they do
is they they take kids from tough areas
you know uh
the kids that are at risk and they try
to help them
make good decisions and so their goal is
to take kids that
might be pointed in the wrong direction
and get that energy directed in a
positive direction
and so it's a great program they
actually they use ex-convicts to kind of
uh come in and talk to these kids
i sat in on one of their sessions and it
uh i don't know how much
impact it had on the kids but it scared
the heck out of me because they talk
about what actually happens if you end
up
in incarcerated and so forth try to get
these kids
some real life stories as to to what can
happen so it's a wonderful local charity
and they're just trying to affect the
lives of a few of these kids and get
them on the right direction
as you guys are involved with so many
charities and the raiders are helping
out with this one too
yeah the raiders just recently uh made a
donation of forty thousand dollars to
real talk which is
which is awesome that's gonna help them
with some of their programs you know
they've got
one of their new programs is a thing
called their uh career prep program and
they're
they're having people in the local
community talk to the kids about their
careers
and so the kids kind of have something
to aspire to and see what's available to
them
they're actually looking for volunteers
if people want to donate
you know about an hour and a half 90
minutes their time as someone that has a
job that wants to talk about
how they got into their position how
they got into their career
to kind of help these kids understand
what's out there so
they'd love to have people in the local
community to do that
so great and you could always use them
helping you have a golf tournament
coming up that will raise funds for this
yeah that's right we're we always are
sponsoring their events and and one of
them is a golf tournament coming up this
this monday over at tpc summer and they
got a few spots left so if somebody
wants to come
have a great day it's gonna be 70
degrees on monday so it'll be a great
day to golf
tpc summerlin is gorgeous and it all
raises money for real talk so we
encourage you to
visit their website and check that out
well tyler as always doing great things
in the community we appreciate your time
very much thanks for joining us
you got it thanks kendall appreciate it
you can see the golf tournament
happening
this monday february 22nd 9 a.m at tpc
summerlin
costs 300 per golfer are one thousand
dollars per foursome to sign up
you can get more information about the
real talk youth impact program
go to realtalkyip.org
we also want to thank findlay automotive
for being one of our community pride
partners